Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you want to apologise?
Listen out for useful language for apologising.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Noelia!
I am so sorry! Are you OK?
I think so.
That was lucky.
I'm really sorry! I didn't see you!
That's all right.
I shouldn't have been running.
No, no, I should have been paying attention.
And they teach you not to run inside at school!
Still, it was my fault and I'm sorry.
I'm sorry too.
It was both of us.
Honestly, it's fine.
I'm fine.
Don't worry about it.
Hey, I saved the laptop though!
Yeah, I'll be there in …
Oh no!
Uh oh!
Ahhhh …
Hello again!
Ooh, I hope Noelia's OK.
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for apologising?
Listen to me and then repeat.
I'm so sorry!
I'm really sorry!
That's all right.
It was my fault.
I'm sorry too.
Honestly, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Try and use some of these phrases the
next time you want to apologise in English.
Bye for now!